[Música]
si ustedes aspiran a trabajar en una
misión espacial que creen que
necesitarían
y el extranjero tener un doctorado tener
mucho dinero trabajar pero la empresa
una agencia espacial
mi nombre es maría fernanda al barco yo
soy cofundadora un empresario espacial
estoy trabajando en una misión espacial
y yo no tengo ninguna de esas cosas yo
creo que para trabajar en el espacio lo
único que necesitamos es pasión
determinación e ideas innovadoras y aquí
en costa rica tenemos todas esas cosas
el problema es que cuando pensamos en el
espacio generalmente sólo pensamos en
astronautas en explorar marte o en
misiones de la luna cuando en realidad
el espacio está lleno de oportunidades
para solucionar problemas que tenemos
aquí en la tierra
por ejemplo sabían que la tecnología
creada para recrear imágenes de la luna
durante las misiones apolo es la
tecnología base que permite hacer
resonancias magnéticas attacks
y que las cámaras de nuestros celulares
que utilizamos todos los días se crearon
para uso espacial porque se necesitaban
cámaras ligeras pequeñas y alta
resolución para las misiones
y sabían que el banano que consumimos y
producimos está en peligro de extinción
y que una posible cura podría estar en
el espacio
existe un enemigo silencioso que una vez
que entró una plantación ataca los datos
de las plantas de banano y comienza a
podridos por dentro
lo que hace difícil detectarlo en sus
primeras etapas y así este enemigo se
propaga rápida y silenciosamente de
forma que para cuando los agricultores
se percata de que está ahí ya tienen una
gran parte de su plantación afectada
este enemigo es un hongo llamado
fusarium oxysporum que causa la plaga
del mal de panamá esta placa ha arrasado
con el 80 por ciento de las plantaciones
de banano en algunas partes de áfrica y
asia y hasta hoy no tenemos ninguna
manera efectiva de controlarlo
hace poco ese hongo ingresó a colombia
y por eso el primero de julio de este
año costa rica decretó una emergencia
nacional fitosanitaria para prevenir la
entrada de ese hongo al país
les estoy contando todo esto porque para
atacar este problema creamos el proyecto
musa kusa es un experimento que está
programado para llevarse a cabo en
estación espacial internacional en el
2022 donde se van a estudiar el hongo
que causa la enfermedad hizo un
antagonista en condiciones de
microgravedad
esto lo vamos a realizar mediante un
cultivo dual que significa que en un
mismo petri vamos a colocar ambos hongos
usaremos sex forum que es el que causa
el mal de panamá y tricolor marciano que
está estudiado y comprobado que es uno
de los mejores controladores biológicos
un controlador biológico es un organismo
capaz de contribuir a la inhibición de
un patógeno y en el caso de estos dos
hongos se han realizado pruebas en
laboratorio en donde se ha determinado
que el trico derma poder reducir la tasa
de crecimiento del usuario
sin embargo cuando cuando los ponemos en
el campo o en condiciones reales no
obtenemos los mismos resultados
es decir no funciona
nuestro objetivo con musa es estudiar el
comportamiento de estos hombres en
microgravedad
entonces a través de cámaras queremos
monitorear su crecimiento y
posteriormente con análisis biológicos
queremos observar sus cambios genéticos
esto con el fin de generar información
útil que podamos replicar y así hallar
un posible tratamiento a esta enfermedad
tan devastadora
todo esto lo vamos a hacer en un cubo de
este tamaño dentro de él van a estar las
muestras con los hongos las cámaras los
sensores y un sistema de comunicación
que nos va a permitir recibir los datos
en tiempo real
una vez que nuestro club llegue a la
estación espacial un astronauta lo va a
tomar y lo va a colocar en una
plataforma llamada ice cube
esta plataforma fue creada para
experimentos de microgravedad dentro de
cubos de este tipo y una vez que nuestro
experimento se ha conectado él va a
funcionar de manera autónoma y una vez
que finalice el tiempo del experimento
se desconecta y se devuelve a tierra
todo esto por un costo aproximado de 120
mil dólares que para ponerlo en
perspectiva es más o menos lo que cuesta
un carro de lujo aquí en costa rica
y así es como se vería el experimento
en las paredes irían colocadas las
muestras y lo que vamos a ver ahorita en
el centro es el sistema adquisición de
datos está compuesto por los sensores el
sistema de comunicación y las cámaras
que nos van a permitir ver el
crecimiento del hongo durante su tiempo
en el espacio
de funcionar vamos a tener un impacto
social y económico enorme el mercado
global del banano está valorado en más
de 1000 millones de dólares los cuales
están centralizados mayor y
mayoritariamente en américa latina
debido a que hasta hace muy poco este
hongo no había llegado a américa
solo en costa rica genera 40 mil empleos
directos y 100.000 empleos indirectos y
en nuestro principal producto de
exportación lo único que lo supera en
los dispositivos médicos pero solo si
tomamos todos los dispositivos médicos y
los colocamos en una sola categoría no
si estamos hablando un producto único
y por eso la emergencia nacional
además alrededor del mundo el banano
forma parte de la dieta básica de más de
400 millones de personas y constituye
una fuente empleo para miles más
y eso es en un mercado en donde en otras
partes del mundo se pierde un 80% de la
producción
pensemos en eso por un momento
imagínense hacer un agricultor y perder
esa cantidad
como cambiaría la vida a las personas
dependientes de ese cultivo si se
lograra reducir estas pérdidas
musa es un proyecto espacial pero el
alcance de sus posibles descubrimientos
es enorme aquí en nuestro planeta y
especialmente para nuestro país
si hace tres años mismo hubieran dicho
que iba a ser trabajando en este
proyecto a 21 años y tan pronto mi
carrera probablemente hubiera pensado
que se volvieron locos
entonces ustedes hacen estar preguntando
cómo hice yo para llegar a trabajar en
este proyecto si no tengo ninguna de las
cosas que les contaba al principio
y bueno yo desde que una chiquita
siempre ha amado a la ciencia y la
tecnología cuando estaba pequeña me
acuerdo con un tiempo que lo único que
yo quería ver era discovery y national
geographic y cuando mis amigas iban
jugar a mi casa y llegaba el momento de
decir que vamos a ver todas en la tele
más de una vez me tocó pelear
y desde entonces yo sabía que si yo no
escogido una carrera en alguna de estas
áreas nunca me lo iba a perdonar
y cuando entré a altec tuve mucha suerte
porque mi segundo año se fundó tex tex
meses el grupo ingeniería aeroespacial
del tec ahí donde me dio la oportunidad
de involucrarme por primera vez en el
espacio y fue donde nació el proyecto
museo
y mi caso no es un caso particular el
equipo musa somos nueve personas
apasionadas por la ciencia del espacio
que fuimos unidas por textos
tenemos que hablar diferentes como
biotecnología mecatrónica computadores y
otras además estamos en etapas
diferentes de nuestras carreras
somos de diferentes lugares tenemos
personas de san carlos de turrialba de
limón de san jose de todo lado
y también tenemos variedad de géneros
dentro del equipo
esta diversidad en nuestro grupo no solo
muestra que muchas personas diferentes
pueden lograrlo sino que también ha sido
clave para el planteamiento del
desarrollo de nuestro proyecto porque
gracias a eso tenemos muchas ideas y
perspectivas diferentes
que enriquecen cada una de nuestras
decisiones
y esto con nuestro esfuerzo
eventualmente serían recompensados y el
año pasado quedamos como finalistas en
el misiones día contest que es una
competencia internacional de misiones
espaciales y gracias a la ayuda de la
corporación bananera nacional logramos
ir a la final de esta competencia en
tokio el año pasado donde ganamos el
primer lugar
actualmente estamos trabajando en
desarrollar los nuevos prototipos del
experimento y realizar las pruebas
necesarias para certificar el cubo para
vuelo y asegurar su funcionamiento
correcto en el espacio
además decidimos hacer este proyecto un
emprendimiento y crear nuestra propia
empresa que en este momento está
hablando con inversionistas y partners
para financiar el proyecto
y bueno para mí llegar a esto desafío
todo lo que yo creía que necesitaba para
trabajar en aeroespacio y demuestra que
como les dije al principio no tenemos
que irnos al extranjero y tenemos que
ser millonarios sino que lo más
importante es nuestra pasión nuestro
esfuerzo y nuestras ideas
y yo sé que más de una persona debe
estar pensando que suena muy bonito lo
que estoy diciendo pero que en realidad
lo que verdaderamente importa para este
tipo de cosas son las capacidades
técnicas
y claro las capacidades técnicas son
importantes
nuestra experiencia ingeniería tiene
mucho que ver con el desarrollo de este
proyecto pero la lección más valiosa que
yo aprendí con moussa es que son el
conocimiento sin todos los demás no nos
lleva a ningún lado
porque en realidad musa nació de que
queríamos hacer un proyecto espacial no
fue que una sola persona un día se
levantó y dijo estudiamos el más de
panamá de microgravedad no si no que es
amor por el espacio y la meta de hacer
un proyecto de este tipo nos lleva a
trabajar por horas en nuestro tiempo
libre para unirnos y para buscar ayuda e
información necesaria para crear este
proyecto y eso fue lo más importante
tenemos que dejar de ver el espacio como
algo lejano y tenemos que cambiar
nuestra perspectiva de sólo buscar
oportunidades externas también crear en
nuestras nuevas oportunidades y
proyectos
en costa rica apenas estamos dando los
primeros pasos hacia la industria
espacial y las oportunidades solo van a
seguir creciendo
ahora y después es más accesible que
nunca y nuestras ciudades innovadoras
sin importar de dónde vengan pueden
llegar a cambiar el mundo gracias
[Música]